Nos dicen: "A continuación se muestran
tres posibles estructuras de resonancia
para el anión tiocianato, SCN¯". Muy bien, aquí
puedes verlas. "Con base en las cargas formales,
¿cuál de las tres estructuras contribuye más
al híbrido de resonancia de SCN¯?" Y nos dan
alguna información extra, nos dan la Escala de
electronegatividad de Pauling de los elementos
de estas estructuras de resonancia, así que
tal vez esto no sea útil para encontrar,
con base en las cargas formales, cuál de las
tres estructuras contribuye más al híbrido de
resonancia del anión tiocianato. Así que pausa el
video e intenta encontrar la respuesta. Muy bien,
trabajemos juntos. Hay dos cosas que queremos
optimizar cuando pensamos en cuál de las tres
estructuras contribuye más al híbrido de
resonancia: primero queremos encontrar
las estructuras de resonancia en las que los
átomos individuales tienen cargas formales,
lo más cercanas posible a 0; vamos a escribirlo:
los átomos individuales tienen cargas formales
lo más cercanas posible a 0. No hablamos de la
carga del ion entero, hablamos de las cargas
formales de los átomos individuales. Y luego la
electronegatividad es útil, ya que queremos ver
si hay alguna carga formal negativa en un
átomo individual que idealmente sea el más
electronegativo de los átomos, entonces, cualquier
carga formal negativa. Una vez más: no estamos
hablando de la carga del ion entero, en un átomo
individual idealmente en el más electronegativo.
Ahora, con estos dos principios en mente,
encontremos cuál de estas estructuras de
resonancia se acerca más a esta estructura ideal.
Para hacer esto, calculemos las cargas formales en
cada una de estas estructuras de resonancia.
Entonces vamos a pensar en cada uno de estos
elementos. Si solamente tuviéramos un átomo libre
que fuera neutro, ¿cuántos electrones de valencia
tendría? Así que hagamos una columna por aquí para
los electrones de valencia. Podemos buscarlos en
nuestra tabla periódica o tal vez ya sepamos que
el carbono tiene 4 electrones de valencia, 6 en
total, pero 4 en su segunda capa. Un átomo neutro
de nitrógeno tiene 5 electrones de valencia, 7
electrones en general, pero 5 en su capa exterior.
Y el azufre tiene 6 electrones de valencia. Y la
forma de calcular la carga formal de los átomos
individuales en cada una de estas estructuras de
resonancia es preguntar: "Oye, ¿cuántos electrones
de valencia tiene normalmente un átomo libre y
neutro de azufre?" Y sabemos que son 6. Después
decir: ¿cuántos electrones externos tenemos
alrededor del azufre en nuestra estructura de
resonancia? Y, bueno, los electrones externos que
podemos ver en este diagrama de Lewis son 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, entonces 5 electrones contra 6 electrones de
valencia que tiene un átomo neutro libre de azufre
típico. Entonces tiene un electrón menos, así que
esperamos aquí una carga formal de +1. Otra
forma de pensarlo es que comúnmente tenemos
6 electrones de valencia y sólo vemos 5 girando
por aquí, en esta estructura de Lewis, por esto es
que obtenemos +1. Podemos hacer lo mismo para el
carbono: el carbono tiene 4 electrones de valencia
típicamente cuando es neutro, y en esta estructura
de Lewis, en esta estructura de resonancia,
vemos que tiene 4 electrones externos alrededor
de él, los mismos que esperábamos para un átomo
neutro de carbono. Entonces, 4 - 4 nos da una
carga formal de 0. Ahora, para el nitrógeno
tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 electrones externos
alrededor de él, mientras que un átomo neutro de
nitrógeno tiene 5 electrones, así que tenemos
2 electrones más: 5 - 7 es lo mismo que -2,
tenemos 2 electrones externos más girando
por aquí de los que normalmente tenemos en
un átomo neutro de nitrógeno. Y, por lo tanto,
tenemos una carga formal de -2. Hagamos lo mismo
con la siguiente estructura de resonancia. Si
seguimos con la misma idea, tengo 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6 electrones externos alrededor del azufre, que
son los mismos electrones de valencia que tiene
un átomo neutro de azufre, por lo tanto, aquí no
tenemos carga formal. Podemos pensarlo como 6 - 6,
lo cual es 0. En el carbono tenemos 4 electrones
externos girando a su alrededor en este diagrama
de Lewis, que son equivalentes a los electrones de
valencia que tiene en un átomo neutro de carbono,
así que una vez más 4 - 4, no tenemos carga formal
por aquí. Por último, si nos movemos al nitrógeno,
tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 electrones externos
alrededor de él, pero el nitrógeno normalmente
tiene 5 electrones de valencia, 5 - 6 es lo mismo
que -1, tenemos 1 electrón extra alrededor de él,
lo que nos da una carga formal de -1 para el
nitrógeno en esta estructura de resonancia. Por
último, pero no por eso menos importante, en esta
estructura de resonancia tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7 electrones externos alrededor del azufre,
un átomo neutro de azufre tiene 6 electrones
de valencia, 6 menos estos 7 nos da un electrón
extra, es decir, obtenemos una carga formal de
-1 para el azufre en esta estructura de resonancia
El carbono aún tiene 4 electrones a su alrededor,
lo que es normal para los electrones de
valencia de un átomo neutro de carbono,
por lo tanto, no tenemos una carga formal por
aquí. Por último, el nitrógeno tiene 1, 2, 3,
4, 5 electrones externos alrededor de él,
que equivalen a los electrones de valencia
del átomo neutro de nitrógeno; entonces 5 - 5, no
tenemos una carga formal. Así que ya lo tenemos,
hemos observado las cargas formales de todas estas
estructuras. Así que observemos esta estructura
ideal. Los átomos individuales tienen cargas
formales lo más cercanas posible a 0. En esta
primera estructura de resonancia tenemos 2 átomos
individuales, cuyas cargas formales no son 0,
y de hecho, el nitrógeno está bastante lejos
de 0, mientras que en las otras estructuras
de resonancia sólo tenemos un átomo cuya carga
formal no es 0. Así que, con base en este primer
principio, me gustan más estas dos estructuras
de resonancia que la primera para contribuir
más al híbrido de resonancia, así que vamos a
cancelarla. Ahora, para elegir entre estas dos,
usemos el segundo principio: cualquier carga
formal negativa en un átomo individual,
idealmente en el más electronegativo, así que con
esta segunda estructura de resonancia la carga
formal negativa está en el nitrógeno, mientras
que nuestra tercera, la carga formal negativa
está en el azufre. Podemos ver en esta tabla que
el nitrógeno es más electronegativo que el azufre,
así que es en la segunda estructura de
resonancia donde tenemos la carga formal
negativa en un átomo que es más electronegativo,
el nitrógeno. Entonces, por estas dos razones,
esta es la estructura que más contribuye
al híbrido de resonancia del tiocianato.